[Music]
hey check this out a new report says
having an active sex life past the age
of 80 is good for your brain ha ha I've
been I know what the punchline to that
joke is really yeah yeah I bet I can
guess it well that's great
cuz it's time to play wait where did
that come from
don't worry about it Andy ok Andy I'm
gonna read the set up one more time and
then you'll have to all right once again
the setup to that joke was a new report
says having an active sex life past the
age of 80 is good for your brain and
guess my punchline but it's terrible for
your back oh I'm sorry any that's
incorrect which means Laraine has
control of the board
weight control of what board and who's
Lorraine hi Lorraine now guess what do
you think you can guess that punch line
I think all right but first let's take a
moment to meet our contestant shall we
so
Thank You Randy
is it Randy I understand whatever we'll
get it I understand that you're the
sidekick for the coolest talk show host
ever and you have no hobbies well I
wouldn't say he's exactly right and
Lorraine it says here that you are a
sketch comedy character and that as soon
as this bit is over you will cease to
exist that's right let's get back to the
game
[Applause]
all right Lorraine it's your turn a new
report says having an active sex life
past the age of 80 is good for your
brain and guess that punch line but it's
bad for the eyes of anyone who
accidentally walks in on you doing
[Applause]
that's fantastic
all right tell Lorraine what she's won
Andy how am I supposed to know what
she's congratulations Lorraine
you've won a four-day spa getaway in
lovely Sedona Arizona is that my voice
you'll relax and restore in this
beautiful spa resort deep in the heart
of Arizona desert country this luxury
spa package is valued at over $2,000 I
love spice that's all the time we have
for guests of guess that punchlines that
whatever hotel they booked themselves
and Conan O'Brien's War guild provided
by Fellowes on linear all right
you